i am still so excited for your power
puff
show i know that you guys are reworking
the pilot do you know what changes
they're hoping to make on that front
i do i can't speak on it yet because
they are still changing
they didn't decide to rework the pilot
because the script leaked i just need to
say that
that wasn't what happened yeah we had to
reshoot it anyway
for a couple reasons it's a really big
piece of ip
and it's tonally very specific like
getting it right
making everybody happy and also making
sure that it like
translates you know it's like it's such
it's so specific
and to modernize it and to make it fit
like a bunch of different things that
don't normally go together it's just
kind of like a puzzle piece so we're
removing some elements and we're
replacing others
and i think the script is gonna get
another whack
and it's it's just gonna be like you
know yeah a slightly different approach
but
everything else is gonna stay the same
you're our hero it's interesting i've
never reshot a pilot before but i'm
actually
very excited at the thought of it
because i was texting the girls and
we're like oh well now we know what
we're doing like what an
amazing thing you never get to do that
as an actor go back and be like what
would i have done differently
and now you have the chemistry all built
up which i think is amazing what has it
been like to take on
such an iconic franchise so much fun
yeah i feel like my whole career i've
been told um
that i'm very cartoonish in the way that
i express
i just think they're like what's the fun
it's like so much less fun like i just
feel very involved
in life and so to be able to have free
reign
to bring a beloved character to life
that i love so much
in a reality that is so obviously
based in reality but it's so fantastical
and over the top and ridiculous and to
have diablo cody at the helm
and like shoot it with other girls who
are so like
we just have so much fun and it's so
like
um it's just exactly what i would want
it to be honestly i cannot say enough
good things about
the show and the character i'm very
excited to have everybody see how it's
coming together i mean what is more fun
than flying around townsville and having
it look like townsville
and like fighting i can't say what we're
fighting but like
what's more fun than that that's the
coolest job ever